are you shocked at the scale of law
breaking in number 10 prime minister how
could you let that happen under your
watch
sure having plenty to say about that
when the things finished uh sam good to
see you are you embarrassed by the scale
of the law breaking inside number 10
home secretary
are you embarrassed
or are you just going to play death to
the scale of the law breaking in number
10
do you still back the prime minister is
it just best to ignore law breaking in
downing street michael gove
or do you have the full confidence of
the prime minister i said
nigel adams have you fixed it for mr
johnson to get through this despite the
scale of law breaking in number 10
it's great to see you too sam wonderful
to be here in stoke a tory mp is getting
restless about what's going on in
downing street chief whit hi sam how are
you doing
your face is there anything boris gotcha
could do wouldn't mean you backed him
i was a great prime minister fine leader
of the country and we're lucky to have
such a
world beating figure leading us so he
has my support and he deserves it he
should have all the support of the
viewers of sky news